but water pours through loss our
cathetus on Spain's Mediterranean coast
this is a seaside town popular with
tourists in a region being battered by
storms and heavy rain the impact of the
deluge further inland can be seen from
the air with buildings in the landscape
swamped by the downpour overnight
emergency teams work to evacuate people
from properties in the flooded town of
Iloilo we've been incommunicado since
this morning the storm came and flooded
all the streets it seemed like a river
I've never seen anything like that the
water almost got inside and the morning
brought no respite rescuers managed to
reach a man whose car had become trapped
on a motorway that looked more like a
river than a road he was holding on to a
traffic signal since we were talking to
him and he wasn't responding the officer
and I jumped in to get him out
the army has been called in to help
people in the worst-affected towns and
villages and work is underway to clear
the debris they should still be holiday
season for this part of Spain but there
have been record-breaking levels of rain
and more is expected Emma Haywood
al-jazeera